[Musique]
très tendues est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils auraient pu nous tirer dessus
dimanche dernier deux jours après la
chute du président ben ali
nous nous retrouvons bloqué dans un
quartier de la banlieue chic de tunis
un bouchon s'est formé à un carrefour et
des gens accourent de toutes parts
qu'est ce qui se passe là
des militaires se positionne au pied
d'un immeuble d'habitation en uniforme
noir
il y a aussi les forces spéciales de la
police elle semble guetter la sortie
d'un habitant de cet immeuble cossu
c'est la famille trabelsi trabelsi un
nom sur toutes les lèvres en tunisie
c'est celui de l'épousé du président
déchu
un an synonymes de corruption et de
clans mafieux pour beaucoup de tunisiens
les esprits s'échauffent et la foule
tentent de s'approcher de l'immeuble
les forces spéciales doivent alors
s'interposer et notre caméra n'est pas
la bienvenue
au même moment un voisin film
l'arrestation de l'individu recherché
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un proche du clan de ben ali à qui
on reproche de s'être enrichis
frauduleusement il s'apprêtait à fuir le
pays quand les forces spéciales ont
arrêté chez lui la foule s'approche
dangereusement du fourgon de police
devant les risques de lynchage les
forces spéciales doivent intervenir
elles tirent en l'air pour dégager le
passage
[Applaudissements]
finalement c'est sous les acclamations
de la foule que la police emmène le
prisonnier
pour les tunisiens
ces arrestations deux proches de
l'ancien dictateur marquait un tournant
historique
trois jours plus tôt le jeudi 13 janvier
le président ben ali semblait encore
tenir le pays après quatre semaines de
manifestations et une centaine de morts
le dictateur au pouvoir depuis 23 ans
annonce qu'il ne se représentera pas aux
prochaines élections
il promet plus de liberté dans les
médias et une baisse des prix des
produits de première nécessité mais cela
ne suffit pas à calmer la rue dès le
lendemain
l'avenue bourguiba les champs elysées de
tunis est noire de monde
comme toujours depuis le début des
événements la manifestation est très
durement réprimées par la police
les tunisiens qui se sont réfugiés sur
les toits ont du mal à cacher leur
émotion
cette nouvelle protestation de masse
aura raison du dictateur il prend la
fuite
lui et sa famille le gouvernement
provisoire décrété l'état d'urgence
la tunisie est alors sur le fil entre
espérance et chaos
nous avons vécu avec les tunisiens cette
révolution en marche
[Musique]
quand nous arrivons à tunis dimanche
dernier la ville porte encore les
stigmates des violences sur la route
nous croisons ces carcasses de voitures
neuves
plus loin dans le centre nous découvrons
une capitale en état de siège chars de
l'armée aux carrefours stratégiques
hélicoptère en patrouille au-dessus des
ministères les forces de l'ordre sont
omniprésentes mais c'est bien quadrillé
quand même à la fois par la police
devant les rares boulangeries ouvertes
de très longues files d'attentes et une
population qui n'a pas encore ravaler sa
colère contre l'ancien dictateur temps
des lacets je rêve c'est les photos de
benhadj à la poubelle l'europe est ce
que vous faites monsieur là
mais manifestement il y en a qui ne
l'acceptent pas seul à sa place à un
temps fou et toi vas t'on maintenant
pourquoi nous on veut apaiser le pays
je n'ai pourquoi tu laisses pas mais va
t'en va t'en
blessé le piéton foutu voile on arrête
de faire du tapage
les gens veulent reprendre le travail
à la joie très bien aussi mais pourquoi
tu laisses pas faire s'il veut s'en
prendre la photo censure par les
journalistes il faut que les
journalistes où est la vérité
l'esl a filmé les chars l'esl a filmé ce
qui censurent laisse la filmer la
réalité est ce que tu vois la seule
contre tous l'homme préfère s'éloigner
et apprend que c'est merdique ça va
fonctionner moi je remercie le bon dieu
merci jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour moi j'ai
vécu tout l'egypte qui ont été passés
l'ancien au liban les vingt trois heures
qu'on appelle du comme ça et voilà je
suis admirative et liberty la bouche qui
nous a manqué
vive la démocratie
aucun symbole du régime ne va résister à
cette volonté de revanche en bord de mer
dans un paysage de carte postale
voici l'une des dernières discothèque à
la mode de la région de tunis ou du
moins ce qu'il en reste car aujourd'hui
deux jours après le départ du président
tunisien
l'établissement est littéralement
désossé des poutres en métal jusqu'au
matelas des banques est tout ce qui peut
se revendre fait l'objet d'un pillage en
règle y compris les stock d'alcool
entreposés dans la cave
qu'est ce que vous faites là
ces réunions ont fait comme tout le
monde on récupère la bière là je t'en
supplie nom à l'image même constat il ne
reste plus grand chose à prendre
si les habitants du quartier ont pillé
ce bâtiment c'est qu'il appartient à
houssen trabelsi l'un des neveux de l'ex
président surnommé le roi des nuits de
tunis un homme d'affaires qui comme le
reste du clan aurait construit sa
fortune sur des détournements de fonds
et si il y à des milliards qui ont été
dépensés alors oui les gens ils ont
raison de faire ça ils ne font que
prendre qui leur est dû deux jours après
la chute du dictateur il n'y a pas que
les palais des dignitaires qui sont la
proie des pillards alors dans cette
période incertaine
la population a dû prendre en main sa
propre sécurité
21h un hélicoptère des forces de l'ordre
survolent la capitale malgré le
couvre-feu qui a commencé quatre heures
plus tôt ils sont des dizaines de or à
veiller sur leurs quartiers au soir
qu'est ce que vous faites là en fait on
garde le deuxième entrées de la cité
c'est vous qui avez installé sa ce qu'il
redoute
ce sont des attaques de miliciens restés
fidèles à ben ali
ils se déplacent en voiture en ambulance
ils ont des armes qui sont des personnes
qui sont des scènes trouve qui veulent
déstabiliser notre pays
nous faire croire que sans ben ali on
n'a pas la sécurité mais notre sécurité
mais avec quoi vous défendez le quartier
avec ses potes là-bas
chacun se débrouille et vont chaque à se
débrouiller avec ce qu'il a c'est quoi
ça une bombe anti agression cette équipe
et vous aussi
c'est quoi ça un arpent carrément pour
pêcher ce soir l'ambiance est bon enfant
la nuit sera calme mais avec ces
citoyens qui font la police la situation
peut vite dégénérer
le lendemain dans la banlieue de tunis
nous tombons cette fois sur un barrage
routier des habitants contrôler tous les
véhicules
regarde bien la voiture et regarde bien
qu'est ce que vous faites ici on cherche
des armes dans les voitures mais
pourquoi vous laissez pas la police
faire le contrôle c'est trop de travail
pour eux ils peuvent pas sont fatigués
c'est trop pour il faut qu'on les aide
il faut que le pays se relève tu
comprends et les plus jeunes aussi
participent à cette mission délicate
celui ci prétend avoir 18 ans c'est pas
une surprise quand même de voir des
jeunes comme ça qu'est bon dieu soit
loué dieu soit loué
c'est des gens du quartier on est
content dieu soit loué
mais quelques minutes plus tard celle
alerte quand une voiture qui
s'approchait vient de faire demi tour
à leurs yeux elle est donc suspecte elle
est aussitôt prise en chasse si vous
nous passez par là il pense que le
conducteur peut être l'un de ses
partisans de l'ancien régime qui sèment
la terreur dans le pays
[Musique]
alors tu as fait demi-tour pour quoi
j'ai oublié mes papiers je vous jure
bessat en descend à genoux alors
pourquoi tu as fait demi tour mais je
vous jure j'ai oublié mon portefeuille
pas du tout puissant je crois est de
retour et nous ton portefeuille les
lavages travail là bas mais personne
là-bas pub a rien fait j'ai rien fait et
on va voir si t'as rien fait j'ai eu
peur pardonnez moi de quoi vous avez
tort j'ai eu peu près ce que tu veux que
je te dise on a peur de quoi tu as peur
ou la voiture volée les gars c'est ma
voiture je vous en prie je suis père de
famille tout en bas je le relève le
relâche rivasi c'est bon on a eu un
doute sur ta voiture on a rattrapé c'est
tout pardonnez-nous mon frère je
pardonne je pardonne cette révolution
tout le monde ya pris sa part les
classes populaires mais aussi la
jeunesse des beaux quartiers ont mal vu
par l'anneau à la et mena ici on rose
est accro au web et depuis quelques
jours elle se régale aujourd'hui elle
veut montrer à sa famille
la dernière vidéo qui fait le buzz en
tunisie il ya nouvelle vidéo en tas à
temps limité
c'est une parodie du dernier discours de
ben ali mais une telle insolence était
encore passible de prison
il y a trois jours en tunisie et n'a en
sait quelque chose
en mai dernier elle avait appelé via son
blog sur internet à manifester contre la
censure
elle a été arrêtée mais ces nouveaux
modes de communication
la police n'y comprenez pas grand chose
ils ne comprenaient rien du tout de ce
qui se passait il savait qu'il y allait
avoir une manifestation d'habitude quand
il ya une manifestation tu as une tête
ou un leader ou un groupe qui organise
les trains ce groupe i les tabards au
revoir et merci
mais là c'était un truc qui a été
diffusé sur le net et moi nous disent et
qui va venir manifester je ne sais pas
il me disait que si tu continues à
mentir tu vas avoir deux gifles je lui
dis mais se mesure que je ne sais pas
qui va venir manifester
finalement c'est il voulait me faire une
pression psychologique mais elle me
faisait des remarques du style tu es
marié je disais non pour patiner pas
mariés mais il était certes importante
mais je disais c'est pas maktoum qui
sait par contre pas mariée je me disais
mais pourquoi parce que tu l'aimés tu as
tes qu'aucun homme ne veut de toi et moi
dans ma tête je me disais ah ok sinon si
on s'arrête en fait que je suis bête est
idiote et qu'aucun homme ne veut de moi
c'est parfait et je faisais aujourd'hui
elle en sourit mais en cette semaine de
l'après révolution les tunisiens sont
encore très inquiet
dans les rues de tunis la question est
dans tous les esprits
qui va diriger le pays car après toutes
ces années de dictature il n'y a pas
beaucoup de nouvelles têtes qui soit
capable de prendre les rênes du pouvoir
à la télévision par exemple tous ceux
qui travaillaient là sous ben ali sont
encore en place mais il ya tout de même
une différence
les journalistes étaient jusqu'ici de
simples porte parole du pouvoir
désormais ils peuvent exercer librement
leur métier et n'ont pas l'habitude
le jour où nous le rendons visite c'est
un peu la panique vous allez annoncer le
nouveau gouvernement c'est ça en direct
en attendant s'il te plaît de loi des
noms qu'elle passe à l'antenne
troc entre deux mois quelques ministères
ou moins les principaux parce que je
n'ai pas encore l'antenne c'est les
boulons ce qu'il a donné là ils sont
juste il ne veut rien dire il m'a dit
d'attendre la fin de la conférence
les cessonnais il ya quelques
technocrates qui sont restés ce sont les
mêmes bons mais qu'est ce que je vais
dire
il s'appelle comment notre journaliste
notre journaliste nous a dit d'attendre
la fin de la conférence de presse de
presse on reprend la fin de la
conférence pour ces journalistes
habitués à régner en maître sur
l'information officielle
c'est un bouleversement ils sont
maintenant en concurrence avec les
autres médias et notamment les
télévisions étrangères
la liste est bonne salisienne avant
comment ça se fait anti pas c'est à dire
que vous vous êtes les derniers avant
l'été dit avoir alors qu'on sait que la
télévision nationale jeudi et la
composition de ce nouveau gouvernement
va provoquer la colère des tunisiens
nous avons pu assister à sa toute
première apparition officielle
parmi les ministres il y à bien deux
nouvelles têtes comme ce jeune homme
très décontracté bonjour vous êtes
monsieur madame bonjour
aïda touihri slim amamou est un ancien
hors la loi il était en prison de la
semaine dernière pour s'être opposé à
ben ali sur internet
slim 33 ans a été nommé secrétaire
d'état à la jeunesse et aux sports à
cause de sa popularité sur le web
mais dans cette nouvelle équipe au
pouvoir il y encore beaucoup de membres
de l'ancien parti du dictateur ben ali
à l'image de foued mebazaa président de
la république par intérim et mohamed
ghannouchi premier ministre
tous deux étaient déjà des dignitaires
sous l'ancien régime et ce maintien de
l'ancienne élite ne plaît pas à tout le
monde
ils ne voleront pas notre révolution et
le vent fort et ne va le régime la tête
est parti mais le gym est toujours là
ils ne voleront pas notre liberté comme
lui mardi matin ils sont de nouveau des
milliers à crier leur colère sur la vie
bourguiba
[Applaudissements]
c'est une pièce de théâtre on n'en veut
pas c'est tout ce qu'ils veulent il en
est pas encore on n'a pas encore fait le
l'état de ce qu'on veut exactement mais
est-ce qu'on veut parle on le sait le
lcd y dégage le rcd c'est le parti de
l'ancien président ben ali
sous la pression des manifestants les
policiers commencent à reculer mais l
approche du ministère de l'intérieur
la foule est dispersée
même si elle est ferme
la répression n'est plus aussi violente
que celle de ces derniers jours qui veut
boire de l'eau mon frère je t'en prie
les policiers soigne et il leur image
devant notre caméra
ils sont aux petits soins pour des
manifestants qu'ils viennent de gaz et à
bâle et ça va aller
ils savent que le peuple a maintenant le
droit à la parole les tunisiens devront
élire leur nouveau président dans les
six mois